hi everyone
my name is jesse galiff i'm part of
etienne's team with the machine learning
r d um generally doing machine learning
and
hoping to focus on interpretable machine
learning i've been with the company for
a little less than a year so i'm still
pretty new and really enjoying
the work so i'm going to talk about some
of our current
tools that we have and some of the tools
we're developing right now
hope to get some questions about
how you would like to use some of the uh
interpretation tools so
uh let's get started
the thing i love about machine learning
is that it is
too smart a surprising amount of my work
in neural nets previously was about
convincing them to be stupider and to
focus on the patterns we wanted them to
this is a an example i really like that
there was
a team trying to predict pneumonia from
x-ray scans and they found a lot of
images from different hospitals and
trained a convolutional neural net which
focused on patterns in the images
and did a really great job until they
tried to figure out why they were doing
so well and it turns out that the
neural net was picking up on particular
tokens and symbols indicating which
hospital
the scan was from and some hospitals or
do a lot more
treating of pneumonia and so it's
possible and very plausible that the
machine learning is picking up on a
pattern you don't actually care about or
that it's uh not going to replicate in
the real world
or picking up on something illegal or
picking up on something that
you know is not causal or maybe it's
picking up on something that is really
exciting and a new discovery
but without having a human in the loop
to look at the
findings it's hard to know quite what to
make of the
patterns so the general approach
that people like to talk about is to
have a human in the loop
looking at the findings of the model and
sort of tweak it
try it again so we both want to know how
well
the model works and how it works so what
does it do well what is it
badly so we can find maybe doing some
feature engineering to
correct some of the problems that it's
having with particular classes
uh what does it do suspiciously well so
sometimes the
answer leads into the training set
and you don't want it to you know find
the uh
the answers i think one case the machine
learning model discovered that it could
tell that alternating images was
you know the answer because the people
didn't randomize their test sets or the
training sets
um but yeah we
want to work with the machine learning
models to
help them help us and possibly explore
data and learn new things because
they're very good at
spotting patterns we're good at
providing context
um but let's get right into it i mean
starting out interpretable models we
should use models that
can be easily interpreted if we think
they'll work and a lot of the time
simple linear regression logistic
regression
will do a great job and they're simple
to understand
the tools that we've been working on in
the machine learning team with
predictor and classifier measurements
allow you to understand a little bit
more what the
how the model is handling the data we
can check the information
and what i've been working on shaft
values is going to be new for 12.2
and i'm going to talk about how it can
be used on single examples to explain
a decision how it can be used to sort of
explore a model
and understand why it's doing what it's
doing
and then get into some of the honestly
some of the philosophical questions
behind what we mean by an explanation
and causation
so um that's when some of the
interesting questions arise and i need
to hear
how people think we should proceed
so obviously um i'm going to walk
through an example here with
a sample data set the wine quality where
you have lots of information about
different bottles of wine and you're
predicting their quality
it's very simple i love this you know
one line
say hey predict the
quality of the wine and it's you know
two lines or somethings is really good
i'm specifying a
linear regression because if we then
call
information on it and we get a handful
of information we can look at the
learning curve so how well it's doing
with different amounts of training data
but also
you know we can just ask for the
function and see exactly what it is
doing it is a linear
model each coefficient is multiplied by
the variable for the bottle of wine and
this isn't
standardized if we um made each
variable mean zero standard deviation
one then the
magnitude of these coefficients would be
how important the
feature is and that's you know very very
handy very simple and they're all these
other
properties that you can use from the
information to
get a sense of the model but not how it
interacts with data not the next except
the victor measurement
so you notice the previous part with
information you didn't
need to test that here you provide a
test set the
predictor you know your model
runs on all of it and you get to see how
it did so
create a predictor object just call
it and ask for the r squared or the mean
square um
it automatically provides this is a
comparison plot
which is the predicted value versus the
actual value you can see
generally how it's doing and there are a
ton of other properties that you can ask
for
um i think some of these you know you
can
just ask for a residual plot and see how
well it does at different
predicted values or take the residuals
and plot the residuals against the
values themself
so here's an independent variable the
total total sulfur dioxide
and just by looking at it we can see
that the residual so how far
the model is off in its prediction are
much higher
in the middle compared to the edges
indicating that it's
doing a good job at high and low amounts
of sulfur dioxide but
in the middle it's getting things wrong
and that makes us think that maybe the
feature isn't linear maybe we should get
a non-linear model
it's pretty useful to be able to poke
around and see these things
and especially so easily with the
wolfram predictor
measurements tool and i'm not a wine
expert so i don't know if this is
um what we can learn from this in
particular but noticing which
predicted examples are the worst so
which it had the hardest time of
uh you know maybe we can notice that it
is doing a bad job with all of the high
sulfur
dioxide wines and we can feature
engineer to help it out but
without knowing wines that's not
something i can really weigh in on
easily
i'm not going to spend much time on it
but classifier measurements is very
similar
you can train a classifier in no time at
all
and then the classifier measurements
object will provide a similar report
but instead of a comparison plot has
these confusion matrices it has
more properties about classification and
accuracy in f1 score and
area under the curve things like that
that are very standard for
understanding how well a model is doing
and which things it's doing well and
poorly
which brings to the chat values this is
what
i've been working on and i'm sorry i
didn't make the acronym but it's
sharply additive explanations the
p from explanations is the last one and
it's a very meta acronym
i guess yeah acronym not initialism uh
referencing shapley game theory concept
which is
uh lloyd shapley won the nobel prize in
economics for this
in 2012 which is a way to attribute
credit
or flame in a group um
and it's a used fairly recently i think
it was 2017.
somebody wrote a paper on this that you
can have a model agnostic approach where
each feature you want to attribute
credit
to the feature for how much it does or
doesn't
affect the prediction and doesn't matter
what the model is we don't need a linear
model we can put anything in as long as
you can
give it an example and get the result
and give it a handful of different
examples and see how it affects the
model's predictions
let's walk through uh
an example of how it would work let's
say we are not
restricting ourselves to a linear model
so again we're gonna do a quick
training on and specify a random force
which is notoriously hard to
interpret this is not linear at all and
train it and we can see that the
the r squared is significantly better
than the linear models
the mean squared error is significantly
lower than the linear model so
this is doing better but it is hard to
interpret it
so we need some some understanding let's
pick a bottle of wine
bottle 42 and again not knowing very
much about wine it's
seems like a fine bottle the true wine
quality was six out of ten
it's a little above average i think or
um
i forget what the exact average is but i
don't know the average of all bottles in
the
set was eight point or five point eight
so this is slightly better than average
but um
so our model on the other hand which is
not perfect predicted
5.2
why that's the question that we want to
answer and
all we need to do at the moment is call
the uh the predictor with the property
shaft value so
just like we would call it on an example
asking for the
the answer or the probabilities in a
classification we ask for the shot
values and get back
these numbers for each feature
so it's saying because of this
bottle's fixed acidity of 9.2 the model
boosted
its prediction by about 0.05
um because of the volatile acidity of
0.34 it lowered
the predicted quality so you can do this
for each of the features
and get a quick chart for how each
feature
impacted the final prediction and see
that
residual sugar was very helpful for
improving the wine quality
in this context and the alcohol and
density were very
bad for it um
the thing about shaft values shapley
additive explanations is that they
add up to the difference between your
prediction and the mean so
the total of all the the shop values for
this bottle
are you know negative six you know 0.61
and we can look at if you take the mean
value of all the y inequality and add
that we get
very close to what the model actually
predicted for our bottle
um so since it's additive you know it's
possible to make a little plot like this
which
i don't know i i enjoy to use the step
plot where it starts at the average
perhaps then because of the density it
lowers its prediction and then because
the alcohol
lowers its prediction but the residual
sugar boosts its prediction back up
and it sort of winds its way and
converges on
the deviation from uh how what it would
say at the middle for the meanwhile
quality
again not going to spend too much time
on how the classifiers are different but
uh it's very similar you just call it as
a property for chat values
and it returns the log odds ratio so um
calling it on the titanic data set
asking whether somebody's likely to have
survived
if the numbers are negative it harmed
their chances of
being as part of this class so we look
at the odds ratio
for this person being in first class
boosted their odds by five so if it was
a
you know two to one chance of surviving
now it's going to be a 10 to 1 chance
of surviving because of their class
so those are each one example of time
but if we do it on
a number of data points we can start
getting an overall picture
and so here i called it on all 500
data points in our test set um it takes
about 20 seconds that's
that's going to be reasonable but
it's not instantaneous we've actually
found ways to simplify it quite a bit
but
you can get future importance by just
taking the absolute value
of the impact this is something that is
common in
random forests and we can predict the
future importance in linear models very
easily
but neural nets uh make it kind of
difficult to assess
feature importance and so using a shaft
values of a number of examples can help
you get the
sort of the overall importance of a
feature
or you can start plotting the feature
values versus their impact
so here's we can look at at different
fixed acidities what was the impact of
the acidity for this bottle
and it's uh you know as the acidity goes
higher it starts
being a very bad thing always in context
so this is a particular bottle
and a particular volatile
acidity citric acid everything else in
that context the fixed acidity
hurt its prediction and we can see lots
of non-linear
production so we can understand more of
what our random forest is doing
a random forest seems to be using the
0.27 or something
value at which point it starts
rapidly penalizing the prediction for
um based on the citroen acid um
we can see oh interesting sulfur dioxide
might be a little bit
uh zigzag or cubic but you know these
are
we can also look at interactions between
the different features to see that
only in high alcohol cases does the
density
being high help the prediction so these
are things that are
you know once you get to play with them
it gives you a real chance look how the
model is doing what it's doing and
possibly explore and find some new
principles
that are you know new to you as a wine
scientist
so what are they um how they work
the theory so i was describing how
important it is that these are
in context for the bottle of wine and
we can't just change the density feed
that
into the model and see what's new
prediction is because what if it
is only important in
combination with a particular acidity or
having an alcohol condense of
eight or this density makes it a
particular prediction and
changing the density isn't going to
affect our
model's prediction yet um so shapley
values this is the game theory
thing that got the nobel prize looks at
every combination of
whether or not you know or don't know
the feature change it or don't change it
so um
if you know the alcohol and acidity
you look at the prediction versus you
know the alcohol acidity
and density if you know the acidity
versus knowing the
acidity and density so in every case you
see what it's like with or without
this particular bottle's density and
look at the prediction
um i found a pretty decent
illustration this is for predicting the
income
from age gender and job and in each case
you want to uh judge how
the model's prediction changes when we
add in
the feature age and adding it all up
in a particular waiting system which is
the shapley
discovery or development
we can explain the difference between
the mean with
no features known you know if you don't
know anything about the person we
predict 50k
in this model and if we know their age
gender and job
we know that they we predict 83 000
and we need to know how much is just age
so we look at it
as we add in age um
this is where it starts to get
philosophical but what do we mean
about by changing the feature um
it's not clear there's discussion and
there are
pros and cons to different approaches
but um
let's take okay so we're trying to
predict heart attack risk
from age blood pressure and salt intake
so here's a
man 72 years old has very high blood
pressure i think
um i think that's very high and has a
high fault diet
and our model says that the heart attack
was high
and we want to know what the impact of
blood pressure was
and so the first approach is asking the
model to infer
the blood pressure um this is the
observational
approach so we could ask the doctor
without
mentioning the blood pressure what do
you predict for a 72 year old man
who has high a high salt diet and the
doctor says well
given the high salt diet he probably has
high blood pressure so he's high risk
and then you say what if i told you his
blood pressure and it's high
yeah that's what i expected he's high
risk
so because those predictions aren't very
different
giving the model the actual blood
pressure or not
it'll attribute less impact to blood
pressure so even if blood pressure is
really important in the model
if you can predict the blood pressure
from his high salt diet
then it's the impact is spread out among
those different features
and that's a little bit weird to think
about the idea that
the model might not use diet at all the
model might only look at blood pressure
but because blood pressure is uh because
the diet is
useful for inferring blood pressure it's
still giving impact um
this is considered being true to the
data but not necessarily true to the
model
when would you want this well proxy
values are
pretty important in understanding the
legality and
um fairness questions
if your model doesn't use race
but you discover that um you know
when race is included you can learn that
it
is predicted that uh zip code is the
classic
case but um zip code in theory might not
matter
but if your model is using it as a proxy
for race
then we can look at it and say that you
know we need to revisit our model and
legality of it so the second approach
is the interventional asking the model
to change blood pressure and see what it
says now so
you ask the same question you know with
72 years old high salt uh the doctor
says that
he only looks at blood pressure and high
risk you say cool
what if we could get the blood pressure
down to a good amount
the doctor might say oh great low risk
and if you ask
if we could change his diet to low salt
but he still had high blood pressure
it doesn't matter blood pressure is this
you know the thing that matters
so in this case looking at the
differences as we tell the doctor his
blood pressure or
dope telling blood pressure or tell them
a different blood pressure
it's very different and so because the
model relies so heavily on blood
pressure we understand its impact
this is true to the model and even if
the salt diet is useful and important
for understanding
in the real world in a causal sense the
model might not
use it at all so this is understanding
more it's being true to the model they
say
but has some downsides as well where
you're not going to
discover proxy values and it might
test your model on ridiculous data so
you're not i mean
it's one thing to say hey maybe we can
give him blood
pressure medication and reduces blood
pressure
but that requires human context
and it's not always easy to know which
values are
sensical we're deliberately throwing out
our
initial understanding of the patient and
accepting some interventions
so we might ask for the risk of cancer
for an 18 year old
given 22 years of taking hormonal birth
control i mean it's not
the model might not work very well in
those contexts to say the least
so these are the general approaches
um at the moment in 12.2 we're going to
be implementing
the observational approach
yes um inferring blood pressure and so
uh understanding your
uh how the model sees the world hits
very metaphorical and
personifying but uh trying to understand
how the model understands the data and
so even if a feature isn't immediately
used
in the model if it's important then
you'll understand it
and this is part of the you know one of
the things that wolfram models have it
has a computer for missing values and
it's going to be better and worse at
predicting missing values based on its
understanding of
getting a large data set which is very
true to
machine learning um so
we're trying to choose how to proceed
with some of the philosophical questions
and how important it is to have
the interventional chat values
to know what applications they're going
to be used for
and so uh i think i have it as a hole
in the in the pathable so i'd love to
get
your input on how you're likely to use
chat values um i should have given a
free answer i'm sorry for that but
uh you know i'd love to hear in the q a
and in the chat
or questions for how it can be used and
how you
have an intuition about you know what
things you're hoping to learn from your
models
i think that is beyond my
yes that is a little beyond my time but
i can take questions i can check the
passable chat
and see
i'm seeing some both interventional and
observations i think they're both really
cool and the more i think about
uh causation and correlation it's very
very tricky um judea pearl's
do calculus as he calls it is the
question if we do this
to the world what happens rather than
looking at just correlations but
since models are so
correlation based machine learning
models are looking for correlations and
it's very hard to sort of imbue them
with a sense of causation so
it's um i think the
observational approach is the one that
we went with first
and that is the easiest to explain in
terms of the model but
um yeah it's really um
it's it's not straightforward to say the
least there's still discussions about it
so real world data is expensive we often
don't have as much of it as we would
like
always uh so we work what we have but
worry that our model pays too much
attention
and overfits the data we have yeah i i
don't know
let me think about the best
i do think even the predictor
and um classifier measurements will do a
decent job of helping you understand
um your model's strengths and weaknesses
the um let me actually go
back to it but the model these
yeah um
is this yeah let's go back to the
information
um so
one thing that is you know helpful is
that even
in a single line call forming a
predictor
model it's trying a number of different
algorithms with different amounts of um
hyper parameter tuning and
regularization and if you don't specify
which
method so i deliberately said hey you
have to use a random forest here
if you don't then it will use
cross-validation to
pick these things and find what's best
which is
i mean without a ton of data it still
says put some aside
train on part of it and then check
on the part that it held out repeatedly
to get a sense of if you can't train on
this exact data
how well can you predict it's i mean
you're still
limited to the data you have but if you
can figure out which data is important
and which features are important
then you might be able to do a better
job and spend your time focused on the
things that are
the most helpful
yes shop can be used for classification
problems let me
i'm hoping that my computer can handle
it but
um let's see the
shaft values example for
yes so here's the um
case with a classifier trying to
understand
why this particular person was given a
um chance of survival or not
classifier
so we can look at the first person's we
can actually look at both the
um probabilities and
shaft values i think let's see if this
works yes okay so the probabilities of
survival the model itself gave them
a quite a good chance of surviving you
know 85
and we can look at the survival
uh the impact on the survival so these
are the
log odds ratio positive is good and
we take the the shaft values
and you know take the exponent of them
then these are the logouts ratio so i
think the average survival was about
uh one to two for about a thirty
percent chance of survival something
like that in this test set
and so if we take well let me actually
um
look at the mean
oh uh
oh that's what i want this is
not the best use of our time i'm sorry
ah all right fine
all right but if it's about a thirty
percent
chance then that's odds of one to two
which is one through three and then we
multiply
by you know about the five which is what
the
class does for us and multiply by 0.78
and multiply by 2.3 and
so these are the odds of survival about
three to one
um which is about 75 and
as just rough estimates um
a three to one odds 75 is very close to
what we predicted um yeah
i see a neat conversation even happening
in the chat
um
i think it'll be interesting to
see how the bayesian models handle
intervention i mean it's still a
question of intervention versus
observational so how much we are
allowing things to intervene versus
look within the data that we already
have so i
don't know that there's a way out of it
but
if you know that you want you know
observational
jab values then i think you know
bayesian models come with a lot of
priors that are really useful
and might make things really quick to
use
i am a little bit over time but i
appreciate everybody coming and feel
free to continue in the chat
i will be around to see the questions
and
feel free to email me jessie g at
wolfram.com
and otherwise have a great rest of the
conference